quand la corvée de linge devient un
plaisir si si c'est possible à tour une
laverie d'un nouveau genre vient
d'ouvrir ses portes à côté des machines
un coffee shop de la petite restauration
et même un espace de coworking ça
s'appelle Charlie et la chocolaterie ce
n'est pas Willy Wonka mais la Turquie
qui nous fait la visite
bienvenue dans le monde enchanté de
Charlie et la chocolaterie le concept
l'avait son linge et en profiter pour
manger un morceau ou s'installer dans
l'espace coworking Tanguy fait partie
des habitués de la maison c'est aussi
pratique parce qu'il y a des personnes
qui sont là donc déjà c'est plus
rassurant et oui bah boire un petit café
comme ça et pas que venir pour la
laverie bah comme je vous dis moi je
viens des fois boire un café ou un thé
même pour prendre un goûter c'est
toujours un plaisir je trouve de venir
ici et l'ambiance est sympa les gérance
sans sympa donc franchement c'est cool
ouvert depuis décembre dernier par
Jennifer et Charlie c'est pour eux une
première dans le monde de
l'entrepreneuriat
[Musique]
merci un investissement total avec un
objectif en tête rendre la corvée du
linge plus attrayante dans un lieu
convivial donc c'est aperçu que dans une
laverie il y avait rien on s'ennuyait
personne par la personne donc on a voulu
redynamiser en fait le côté l'abri avec
en créant un espace donc détente de
façon à ce que le temps passe plus vite
un lieu multifonction et aussi dans une
démarche écologique du côté du mobilier
tout est 100% fait main avec du bois de
palette recyclée et pour les machines à
laver elles sont fabriquées dans la
région à Lamotte-Beuvron on a 20%
d'économies sur l'électricité sur les
lavages des machines à laver et pareil
la consommation d'eau se fait en
fonction de la quantité de linge que la
personne va mettre dans le tambour et
non par rapport à la capacité réelle de
la machine on essaye de penser à notre
planète et de faire attention à notre
échelle
Charlie et la chocolaterie s'est ouvert
tous les jours de 8h30 à 20h et pour le
dimanche c'est à partir de 11 heures